mattias you took part in a panel
discussion today about do we really need
fiber now before you tell me your answer
tell me about your organization and then
the main points that you were making to
that panel okay i am the chairman of
cable europe which is basically the
european organization of all cable
operators like upc like kabul
deutschland like virgin so we are
assembling the interests of the cable
industry in in europe
and coming back to your question do we
really need fiber i think fiber is
everywhere you know even the cable
networks have a lot of fiber in their
backbones and fiber obviously will go
very closer to the house incrementally
because the development of the download
of broadband traffic will need that you
know but the cable industry does it
incrementally and we only discuss the
very very last mile
and in the very last mile the copper
network which cable has
is like a kind of a gold mine
because our technicians our engineers
invented a standard called boxes i don't
go to the details
who is able now and i just got some news
about it to develop gigabytes
symmetrical both ways over this last
mile in cable
so i think if there is a cable network
and that's in 50
of the european households we take
advantage of that because we could
immediately offer people already now 500
megabits with the old standard with a
new standard we could offer them
gigabits so we think this system this
hybrid system will be fit for a long
time fit for purpose and the advantages
you can incrementally invest you don't
need this big money of investment at a
time to
to take up a fiber network to the house
you know and the customer doesn't notice
he has the same kind of quality the same
kind of experience and service so that's
the only thing we're discussing and if
there would be no cable network
i think even cable operators would sink
in a green field to invest directly in
fiber to the home maybe maybe but it's
up to the operators to do that but it
would be a big mistake to underestimate
the value for the existing cable
infrastructure in the last mile and
while all this is going on what's your
view on the regulatory situation at the
moment
it hasn't been that bad because it's
encouraged especially infrastructure
based competition
and cable our members are one of the
main driving force for high quality
broadband in europe
and our members benefit from this
infrastructure competition and in areas
where you have hundred percent cable
coverage we have the best service all
over europe
so i think infrastructure competition is
one key for get a quality get better
quality and broadband and when
competition works we could phase out of
regulation this is already embedded in
the existing regulatory framework that
could be a little bit enhanced for next
generation networks where you look
market by market but i think there is no
longer a justification for regulation if
this infrastructure competition has so
fantastic results for the consumer yes
now you're finished with the magic word
the consumer there sometimes we forget
about the consumer what do you think
matters most to them at the moment
i think consumers want to have a
seamless experience and they want to
have a whole bundle of different
services uh at a very reasonable price
and that's what cable operators can
offer you know we have embedded wi-fi
systems we have embedded even content
even high quality content in a triple
play bundle you know so it's important
not to think only about infrastructure
it's important to think about the
services and what we see right now is we
are running ahead of the demand you know
so we would like the politicians and the
regulator and the eu commission to look
more on the side of the demand what can
we do to stimulate more the demand of
new services and that's a holistic view
i think for digital europe
and we will deliver i'm sure we will
deliver the best infrastructure
broadband solution
which is technically feasible yes i mean
talking about the eu what do you think
is the one single thing they could do to
help sort of deliver on this digital
single market
besides the demand stimulation and
besides thinking about it
i think they the the regulation which
they do should enable investment i think
that's a key issue because public money
public funding never can do the job you
know most of the money is coming from
private companies and from private
investors
and they are very sensible on changes in
the regulatory framework so what we
should do is to look on these private
investors who by the way have delivered
a great job in the past it's not that
they have done nothing you know they
have delivered very good quality and
listen a little bit more what these
investors want and then in the end of
the day the investors listen also on the
demand of the customers you know so
if you want to have a good business in a
competitive environment
there is no way that you have to listen
to your customer and to support the
needs of the customer so this is a
healthy environment and i think we
should learn out of this healthy
environment and not distorting it that's
the main my main message to the
commission
thank you very much for talking to us
thank you brad